i remember the first week my children
said can you go up to the toilets there
and just check on that patient
and i went up and the next minute he had
me by the neck
and he was trying to strangle me and it
was fight or flight
[Music]
how and why did you decide to start a
career in mental health
i left school with no qualifications
and i just took a part-time job at a
cash and carry store i remember a chap
coming up with his family
to look at a radio and i went up onto
the ladder
to get this radio down and uh just as i
came down
the chat collapsed and banged his head
on the glass cabinet
and unknown to me it had a heart attack
and he had died right out
and i thought throughout that for for
quite a few months after
um i felt that i could have
done something and it was my uh manager
who was a ex-retired mental health nurse
who said to me
paul it's really playing you up you know
why don't you go down the route of
nursing
and uh it was a hospital called saint
lawrence's in bobbin cornwall and i
applied for this job i didn't tell my
family because they probably thought oh
my gosh because i was a bit of a rebel
in the family
and i went for the interview and a
couple of days later i received this
letter to say that i've been accepted as
a nursing assistant as i went in on my
first day
i i really grew up it really made me
think oh my gosh this is a different
world all together
and they put me on a ward that was
extremely busy
um it was an admission ward
uh where patients came in and they were
assessed
um but eventually i worked on most wards
in saint lawrence's
what kind of illnesses were you dealing
with at saint lawrence
the kind of illnesses patients had were
schizophrenia
manic-depressive
depression
ocd
anxiety
and of course not forgetting uh back
then you know some 40 years ago
you would have what they call back then
uh by the lay person as a village idiot
who maybe has gone out and smashed up a
telephone kiosk
and has become a bit of a problem in the
community they were actually sent to st
lawrence's and they'd been there for a
long time
you were very young when you started how
did it feel to be there surrounded by
people with this quite severe mental
health issues it was quite harrowing to
be honest with you i remember the first
week my charger said can you go up to
the toilets there and just check on that
patient
and i went up and the next minute he had
me by the neck and we had white coats on
um and he was trying to strangle me and
it was fight or flight you know i
it really shook me up and i came out and
i thought well one thing here don't
leave yourself you know don't become
complacent there was a lot of violence i
mean it didn't happen every day but you
got to realize that
you know on each ward with that volume
of patience
um
living under one roof
there would be tension and of course the
illnesses and if somebody's paranoid or
delusional
there are cases where
um they think you're that you're after
them you're going to attack them so they
would attack you first and i remember
talking to a patient who i had a good
therapeutic relationship with
and uh this he just stared at me and i
thought
this is
something's going on here and i said to
him are you okay
no he said uh the the voices are telling
me to kill you
and it was so real to him you know you
have to be a certain person to go into
nursing and those that aren't the
certain people they stand out
you know and i've i often had that as a
ward manager recruiting staff
you could just tell the you know if
somebody's
empathetic and uh they're a caring
person and there's a line you know
you've got to be
you've got to be strong and you've got
to you know there's boundaries with
patients etc
but it's all a skill all these are
skills you learn
over time you know and and when you
leave your shift it's about leaving it
all behind and not taking it home
when did you make a decision to move to
broadmoor hospital and why did you do
that
um on my last ward at st lawrence's
hospital
we had a lot of patients who had been at
braumer hospital for some i mean back
then people were there for 30 40 years
some are there for life i thought well
you can't go any higher than this you
know i've worked in a few hospitals but
this is the hospital where
patients can't be managed anywhere else
that's why they go to high secure
hospitals
so basically broadmoor is the place
where a lot of criminals are held just
because they otherwise present a threat
to society and they need constant
psychiatric support is that right well
that is correct but um not all of them i
mean what you get is you get um say
somebody was sentenced to prison
for 10 15 years if they had a relapse if
they had any mental health issues and
they were
category a etc
they would come to a high secure
hospital whether that's brought more
ramp than ashworth etcetera
and there they would be treated under
that security with medication
once they uh
became well
they would transfer back to prison so
it's hopping from one to the other and
some people just continue to do that you
know people who have been sentenced to
life
what kind of criminals did you meet at
broadmoor
well i mean you know everybody knows
who's who's been at broadmoor and who
was there but um
you know it's it's the usual ronnie cray
and peter sutcliffe
there's quite a few of them which you
what you would call the infamous
patience of uh broadmoor but i have to
say if i give you an example you know we
had one patient um
who was filming he he was in a lot of
soaps etc with no names given
and he went off set he became quite
psychotic and he went off and um
he killed somebody
on the street
and he was sentenced to broad war and i
remember all the work we did with that
chap
and then there's some coverage that came
up about five years later in one of the
the tabloids and um
you could just see how he deteriorated
through that coverage it was just like
oh my gosh you know
this is happening a real effect
on him you know
there was quite a lot of examples of
different um
criminals that were in psychiatric
hospitals who created a lot of art like
charlie bronson or ronnie craig
i think that's the the
the only means at that time that they
can get through to people especially the
staff you know i know a lot of
psychologists have said art is the
a huge theme when it comes to breaking
down those barriers with a patient and
building that trust that's why an art
therapist is so paramount on a unit and
it's about somebody who's who if i give
you an example
is quite depressed and they won't speak
you know there's no communication going
on
um they'll do it in their picture
they draw something and you can ask you
can go
in depth with it you know what does this
mean what you put this here what does
that mean
what was the security like and what was
the training like
you're you're trained to use um
what was called control and restraint
back then
and that i believe came from british
airways at the very beginning because of
passengers on flights who were
becoming problematic and that that
carried over and the high secure
hospitals did that first so you are
trained in that and so if somebody um
attacked you you have those those uh
different holes that you put on et
cetera
it's all because it's safe you know as
nobody gets hurt
and then i went on to do the shield
training so that's like what the prisons
do so if somebody did have a weapon you
would bring the shields out and
um
restrain somebody with the shields that
was very interesting
because nobody likes violence nobody
wants violence and somebody who's unwell
who doesn't realize that they're doing
these things
it's about making it safe you know
because people
many many years ago have actually died
through restraints you've always got to
think a couple of steps ahead you would
never go in a room first a patient's
room you would always have somebody with
you you would never leave yourself in a
corner
there's been times and i know
there were two patients
one morning fighting in the day room
and the alarm bells went and everybody
came in and i actually
ended up on the patients holding the
patient's head this is all through
your techniques that you were taught
and we went into the seclusion room and
the seclusion rooms used at the last
resort it's about bringing somebody down
who's maybe gone from not to 10 in an
arousal state
with aggression
and
i remember holding the head
and you always numbered everybody you
wouldn't call them the staff their names
because you might have somebody with the
same names
and i said number one leave the room and
they went out the room and i had the
head and we turned them around so i had
the legs then
number two leave the room and just as i
was about to
you know spring backwards to be caught
by the staff the door closed
and for whatever reason nobody really
forgot this there that um
they thought i'd actually got out i was
out of the room and they shut the door
of course there's the patient who jumped
up off the bed
and to me all i could think of is like
hostage you're now a hostage now it was
it seemed like forever but it wasn't it
was maybe 10 15 seconds because that was
enough
to make me think oh my gosh you know how
did you manage to get out of that one um
that one there i actually they pulled me
out and they went back in and restrained
the patient again and all came out
and um
i think the staff just couldn't believe
it but it's still talked about today you
know
it's one of those incidents which i've
seen a few and being involved in
that always stayed with me you know
because we had hostage training as well
and when you go deep into that it's um
it can be quite scary
what would be the most disturbing things
you witnessed at broadmoor hospital you
think
cutting
when somebody's cut their throat
that that's i mean it doesn't have to be
bromo it can be any other hospital
but that's quite
something you know you deal with it but
it's it's something and obviously when
somebody's um hung themselves that's
that's quite uh especially when you've
got somebody so young
i've come across a few that have been
very young and you just think
it makes you feel how lucky you are when
you leave a shift you know when you've
got somebody talking to you and smiling
and having a good job there's no there's
no indication that you're they're going
to go and do something you know usually
you can see triggers with somebody you
see triggers like their hands or the way
they're looking you know that patient
inside out really
um but when somebody doesn't do that and
they're happy go lucky and then five
minutes later they're they've they've
got a sheet around their neck
you think there's no indication there
you wouldn't have put that person on
observations because they didn't need
them you know
and what i learned through my career
with hangings etcetera is that
if they're going to do it
they'll do it
they really will whether it's in the
hospital or the grounds
they'll do it but there's been lots of
things throughout the career where you
thought oh my gosh you know um
you just wouldn't see that anywhere else
you know and then you go you'd finish
your shift after a horrific shift i mean
not every day's like that
and you go into the supermarket and
you'd have a young lady going
afternoon how was your day you know you
think if only you knew
and you do have a bit of guilt you think
all the time all the
all the input we've given that person
and you you feel like you've you've let
them down you know
have it ever happened to anyone who you
were kind of connected to yeah oh yeah
yeah i mean you know when you're
when you're especially at bloomberg when
you're um nursing there
you are given so many patients to look
after so that would be care plans
um reviews you they're named nurse so
you do build up that rapport
they call it unconditional positive
regard where you've got to put
everything to one side i'll give you an
example of that
if you know a patient's being
transferred up to you and you have read
the notes that can have an effect before
the person's walked on the unit
if you haven't read the notes and you
build a rapport
and read them later
you seem to have that connection more of
a connection it's all those different
things like silence is the most powerful
thing where some people would be so
uncomfortable with it that's a time for
reflection for the person to
think about what you've said or for me
as well
it's about um
all the different things you would ask
and what you wouldn't ask i mean you you
have to challenge some patients but you
wouldn't just go in on your own and
challenge them
whatever it may be you'd make sure that
you had support with you
what do you say
you liked most about your job there's
lots of funny things over time you know
when you've got to have that sense of
humor and i have to say the patients
would have a real
laugh with you as well you know and
that's what it was all about
but the chap who
went running to the toilet and i said
are you all right oh he said i've got
the
the runs and he went off to the toilet
and i thought you've been gone a while
so
um i went up to the toilet and i shouted
the chap's name we'll just call him joe
i said joe are you all right he said
well no he said the doctors have given
me some souls
and that's not working out very well and
i said salt what do you mean souls
well he said i went to the ward round
and instead of prescribing me medication
he said just take some souls
so when i he i said open the door a
minute open the door of course there's
feces all over the walls and that i said
what kind of soaps did you take he said
somersaults
and i thought that was really you know
from somebody who's
yeah there
yeah
why did you make a decision to leave
your career of psychiatric nurse
um through
35 years
i could retire
and
i had a good pension and a lump sum
and i thought it was time to go but i
didn't leave mental health i left as a
ward manager i retired got my 35 years
and continued to work
voluntary um in lots of organizations
i've always been linked
uh to
to mental health always you know and by
going around doing surveys around the
united kingdom
meeting so many different people and you
know it's fantastic yeah do you miss
being
at the hospital sometimes i do when i go
and visit units and
support staff
uh
it takes you all back being on the units
and patients will always come up to you
not even knowing you
and they'll say oh hello paul pleased to
meet you and all that and
you can tell you're a nurse you know
it's quite amazing really but you never
lose those skills you can build you know
you can have that rapport right away you
can converse and that's the biggest
thing in nursing is getting through to
somebody but i always see it as a
privilege to work somewhere like that
absolute privilege you know if you can
just change somebody a little bit like
that each day
that's good enough for me because you
can't expect everything you know people
don't get well over overnight but if you
make that little bit of happiness
um and and uh
make their day worthwhile that that's
good for me and that's why i was in the
job
[Music]
yeah he said you know he said um you
know
um
you'll read him well and um you've got
this
this diagnosis schizoaffective disorder
i kind of thought my life was over as
soon as i've got that diagnosis